The Joe Rogan experience.
Girls Get mad at you about the way your friends dress.
Tell him to stop dressing like that or the way your friend,
your friends act.
Why does he do that?
Why does he think that's funny to throw stuff to do that?
Well cause he's funny.
It's fun.
When he does that,
I don't like it.
So good thing you and I are the same person.
Yeah.
And you know what?
I can replace you.
Oh.
Oh,
that's a threat.
You shouldn't say that to people.
They feel like you might,
you might replace,
are we all replaceable in every way?
Literally we're all replaceable.
I had Lex Friedman on yesterday from Mit.
He's a a,
a autonomous vehicle expert in artificial intelligence expert.
Creepy,
interesting stuff.
But one of the things we were talking about was like the movie her and that his
ultimate goal is to create something that provides companionship to people.
I'm like,
Dude.
So immediately I think,
can you fuck it?
And then I think if it's a guy and it provides a see if you want to gay
boyfriend,
sure.
Can you make it be gay for you?
And that was like the big question.
Like if it is so smart that it's like literally like a companion.
What if it's not gay?
And he was saying we have to face the fact that robots are going to leave us or
grow.
We're going to make robots that leave us.
What the fuck's the point and making a robot unless it leaves you.
What the fuck.
And then there was an article about a peta that was mad at the folks that work
at Boston Dynamics because Boston dynamics,
they make all these crazy robots and they have incredible balance and they can
go running down hills and shit and do back flips.
So these engineers were kicking these robots to try to demonstrate real dog?
Well the devil,
no,
they didn't take,
it was a real dog.
They were demonstrating that it,
you know,
it can react to pressure and it has balanced.
Sure.
So Peter got mad and said they didn't think it was cool that you kick robots.
They're really talking about,
I don't know why anybody would want to do that too because here I have to find
out if you can.
The only way to find out is your fucking engineering works is you kick kick it.
It doesn't have feelings.
You fuck,
but it does Joe.
That's where you're making mistakes in the type of person that you have to be to
say,
I just don't think why any reasonable person in front of kids got robot cause
you've got to find out if you can kick her fucking robot.
How about this?
Come on,
I'll,
I'll pad that robot up and kick the fucking shit out of it for a workout.
Like I would like a robot that I could kick.
That'd be dope.
I would like a robot that I could kick locks,
heads and move.
Yeah.
Oh I want to hit it.
Oh,
you want to hit it?
Yes.
All right.
I would like fuck pads.
I want to be able to tee off on a robot,
man.
If you have a return fight back though,
it looked,
what if it moves at like 30 or 40% that's all I want.
I want it to be a little dangerous,
but I want to be able to get my shots off,
but how do you notice not gonna fucking kill you?
I don't say that it's probably going to happen.
It's not going to hurt it.
Oh,
it's going to hurt you.
You know when I would know when I throw a leg kick and it checks it and I hurt
my Shin,
I'm like,
oh no.
When you hear called Shin Shin on me and then it starts lifting up his front leg
and pressing for it.
I'm like,
oh my God,
my role was going to fuck me up.
I fucked up.
I got it mad and stomps on your fucking,
yeah,
you would have to get something,
a robot that's made out of like heavy bag material on the outside and then the
inside would just be some sort of a wire frame work that moves fairly crudely.
How do you stop it?
This is the thing.
You're creating a world where we're going to get killed by robots.
How do you stop it?
That's the real question.
The real question is what happens when they get so smart and so powerful that
they're tired of our nonsense and this is going to happen?
What Lex and I were discussing and he was talking about all the beauty in being
a person and the meaning and the meaning that we have being a person and I was
agreeing with them.
I mean,
I love people.
I think that's one of the things that's interesting about us is how much we
appreciate the things that we all do.
We appreciate other people's art inspiration even we appreciate the way people
look.
We'd love,
we appreciate that.
Yeah.
Something about the robots don't give a fuck about all that.
The,
my worry is that we could turn something on that you can never turn back if they
become sentient,
if they have the ability to do whatever they want,
whenever they want to,
and they look at us when the sperm whales with 150 flip flops in there,
but they're going to go,
what the fuck is wrong with people?
Have,
we've got a flux.
Are they doing?
Look,
look how gross they are.
They,
they eat all the fish and they throw their plastic in the water and whales are
eating.
They're plastic and dying and they would look at all the stuff we do and then
we'd go,
why and kill us?
Why are we don't need you around?
You guys are worthless.
Well,
we are so egotistical and so egocentric that we can't imagine a world with
meaning without us,
right?
Because we are everything.
But even though we're finite,
even only,
only only exist for a certain amount of time believe leave behind a legacy that
other people could enjoy.
It doesn't matter if they're going to die too,
though,
does it?
But it does matter.
It matters while you're alive.
Okay.
Got It.
The universe doesn't give a fuck about all that and all these crazy robots to
take over.
Imagine if we got to a planet one day,
like imagine if we traveled the universe and we managed to avoid creating some
sort of artificial intelligence because we got hit with a solar flare that
killed the fucking power grid or something like that.
And when we got wiser as a civilization and we got to a place where we could
travel and we travel to another planet and we got there and those robots,
just robots,
no humans,
and they were just running around aimlessly because they'd killed off all the
biological life and they just sit in there operating on the sun with nothing to
do and no purpose and no reason to exist.
And like what happened,
that is crazy monkeys that lived on this planet.
They decided to for an experiment,
make an artificial intelligence and just let it go.
Run a muck.
And what it did was eat everything.
It lived off biological material to,
there was nothing left and then it just sat there in the sun and waited for
someone to arrive.
No,
that can never happen.
Of course it could.
That's happening.
Of course.
Thinking too deeply about where I'm going to be when that happens.
It was Boston dynamic.
Robots are going to have little pinchers on each.
I'm just wrapping everything in front of them and stuffing them in their big
giant mouth.
Cha Cha.
What about the,
what about the robots that turn back on?
Didn't that happen?
Where was that?
Right.
That is shut a robot down in Korea because it turned itself back on after we
shut off.
That's what's happening.
That's what's going to happen.
The the robots are going to start going,
ah,
I want to be on right now.
I don't like being off it.
Wasn't that something that they were doing with Google artificial does it?
We'll just say people in new study struggled to turn off a robot when they
begged them not to.
Oh,
[inaudible] not too creepy.
I somehow felt sorry for him.
Whoa.
Please don't turn me off.
Joe,
do that.
I'm telling you when that becomes a real woman like x Mokena Yep.
And you're in love with her and she tells you to kill your boss.
Yep.
I want to be with you,
Andrew.
You don't need to go to work cherries for fool.
Jamie won't let us leave.
Jamie doesn't think I'm a real woman.
That I know you do.
What if like,
oh,
we got to that happen that were on the way to that happening and we made a deal
with them to leave us alone and we got to go to North Sentinel island to exist.
Uncontacted showing them what would you rather be eaten by a robot or live like
a savage savage.
Oh my God,
I need a of week.
Let me live off the grid forever like that.
As long as you're in a resource rich place,
I would tell you wouldn't be that bad.
They've lived there for a long time.
It's the size of Manhattan.
There's only 39 of them though.
That ain't good.
Yeah,
but that's also because how can they repopulate their fucking each other?
That's what I'm saying.
So how are you?
Can only repopulate so much.
You can only continue to repopulate within your own.
Right.
What kind of gene pool they drawn from this?
Only 39 of them.
They have to be fucking relatives.
They're all relatives.
There's no way they've got it.
There's no way they have a map on the island of people that they're like,
you can't fuck her.
Remember,
just keep that in mind.
They're like,
well,
there's only 17 choices.
Yeah,
it's only 39 and I bet you there,
I wonder if it's how many,
if it's male versus female,
what it is.
I bet it's more dominantly percent men.
Yeah.
Fighting for 15 girls or bought fucking [inaudible] get him the girls to get
pregnant.
They're only 39 of them because they're all gay and like they go,
it's time to make a baby.
Like,
no,
no.
Wow.
Hey Girls that crows and they run up to the tree tops.
Start Banging each other and looking at the girls.
Yeah.
Girls get really mad because they want a baby surrounded by all these days.
So damage said that to set the story of Sentinel Island,
dammit.